we have guest special guest special
guest um I think well it's a surprise
for me too
so my guest is is Wesley so I haven't
been told who we have but it is Wesley
Wesley welcome back to the show
hopefully with better audio today tell
us a bit about this game uh how did you
approach
it uh yeah well thanks for having me
hopefully you can hear me better than
yesterday right I wasn't sure if you
could hear me at all but it's good to
see you guys
well yeah I mean I just you know wanted
to play I mean I noticed that Darius has
been playing a lot of different openings
lately so I didn't actually think he
would go for one E4 considering he tried
that before against me and uh yeah I
mean I got to learn a different opening
than the
Berlin I I mean I looked at magnus games
and then he you know he plays like the
perk he plays the Sicilian Knight C six
he plays the pen plays the knorf he
mentioned I got I got he mentioned the
game from the singfield cup when uh he
got overconfident in his position with
the white pieces over pushed and then
lost were you hoping that those type of
Dynamics will play once again in today's
game uh yeah yeah for sure but they're
very unlikely to I guess they're not
likely to happen because everyone knows
I played the Berlin but yeah that was uh
that was a good game that was a good
tournament for me uh that one in the
singfield cup and not a good one for
Darius
so um yeah he's I mean he's a very
strong player he's very well prepared
he's very aggressive uh he knows his
stuff in the Sicilian so I did consider
playing the nidorf uh at some point but
uh I wasn't sure that he was going to
play one E4 I mean for sure you know if
you're opponent wanted to play he could
over push but also against the Berlin
there are many safe lines that white can
choose from but again you know it's it's
a it's it's still early on in the
tournament Wesley talking specifically
about this uh US championships do you
worry about making too many draws or do
you think that you're going to have
probably something like 11 eight draws
and maybe a few wins what is your
approach to draws in general in this
Championship yeah it's actually a good
question I mean last year I lost two
games yeah
against one against a 15y old
so you know Christopher you yes but yeah
yeah he's very good uh but uh in 2021 I
won the tournament with two wins and no
losses so I mean there are advantages
and disadvantages to both Pro coaches
but uh at some point you just got to
start winning some games and see how it
goes
um uh you know it's it's hard to say but
some point you just got to make a move I
think in
2018 I won my first two games and then
drew the
rest and in 2016 I also started on fire
like winning the first two games as well
I
think so so
uh yeah I mean it's I I think you have
to keep it balanced but at the same time
you got you got to make a move at some
point yeah perfect well thank you so
much ble oh yeah thank you very much uh
uh Wesley indeed as uh we go uh to break
we'd like to leave you with s